okay so here we are here we are our
super duper best friend Adam has asked
us to make some cheesy potato concoction
how'd it go it doesn't look like
potatoes it looks like marshmallow fluff
and they got like a big paddle it was
like tableside guacamole ptheir like
cheese wizards you know in the Olympics
when they have the streamer competition
what's that called I don't I'm not a big
Olympics guy what kind of cheese do we
need tio mmm
Tom Tom means cheese Tom means cheese so
no you can't just say we need to change
there's also cheese I think Tom is a
type of cheese it's a type of cheese is
a class of cheese produced mainly in the
French Alps and in Switzerland we just
call places I hate talking to people on
the phone I'll do the talking
I I wanted to check if you have a
particular kind of cheese I think it's
called Tom de al version or something
like that oh there's no okay thank you
so we have none of the things to make
them know so we need to use potato
butter heavy cream only a pot in a
paddle big kitchen we can try okay I'm
looking for like like a large flat
wooden spoon almost like a paddle but
not quite that large we're looking for a
wood paddle
a nice big one let's go yay
got it
told over I don't know how much cheese's
it's about four pounds causes like a
hundred fifty bucks but it is the right
kind we got all that maker yeah core
paddle okay and we also got this cheese
this is the tongue don't ya okay and so
the first thing that we have to do is
boil these potatoes yeah how do you want
to do that we're going to kill these
that we didn't get a peeler get to
Bueller's good this week
there is nothing appealing about this
scenario I think we just double the
recipe no no yes no that's a bad idea
no it's not fine but if it doesn't work
and it's disgusting and we're out of
potatoes it's your fault I'm okay with
that
aprons his apron a French word how does
this work
oh I see okay so what we also need to do
is to watch our disease for Pentos
I just asked Adam why he cast you and I
together and his answer was we're both
interested in cooking but inexplicably
bad at it Toyota's coming in team work
all right we're going to start heating
it up is so messy so how do we do this
we start with a little I'll just light
up at first oh it's pretty stinky can
they just show up smelling like that
little bit we don't really know much
about this cheese do we yeah it smells
like a Bunny's cage it's like that
combination of grassy pellet food and
poops
[Music]
yeah I'd hit you now so this is so
stinky we had to get somebody else to
smell it so like from here can you start
to smell it already
come take away it's like something I've
never smelled before it doesn't taste
like it does smell thank goodness for
that
alright so the potatoes are done they
are soft and we're gonna put them
through this food mill Wow that's gonna
be a lot of work here let me try some
so Adam thinks we're gonna mess up and
says that we should reserve some of each
of the ingredients so we're gonna go
with that that's kind of what I said at
the beginning mmm
Adam put it more concisely
do you want to hold it in and I'll stir
yeah that's a good idea
it smells really good
so you would have been easier if we
started out with less sorry well it's
not like okay this is what it should
look like I think we got a long ways to
go there's this a perfectly smooth
texture that's my arse needs to melt
more we're on the right track you just
got to keep mixing or not okay what if
we downsize okay so we have in this
smaller proportion we're gonna try a
different ratio cheese because maybe I
think we maybe have too many potatoes I
wonder whose fault it is this I think
we're gonna need more than two pounds of
potato I think we just double the recipe
now keep going keep stirring it's gotta
heat up look you can barely get it to
here that guy in the video was like up
to here almost okay so that didn't
really work out we got close with the
texture but it's nowhere near the
consistency from the video I did a
little more research and I found a few
recipes where they puree the potatoes in
the food processor with the butter and
the cream that already gives it a better
starting texture it's like potato milk I
didn't know that you could whip potatoes
like this and this is what would happen
do you want the big special it sorts it
pick it up so I think Andrews in a bit
of a blind fury Adam tried working on my
revised version which is okay but not
quite
his ridiculous yeah no go away it's
gonna be alright
it's tits good cheese tastes like it's
taste expensive so you use of everything
on the first try it looks so easy the
ingredient list is so easy but man the
technique was just not can we go home
now you gotta go service to people who's
gonna eat this Wow it's good
it's a lot I'll just go 1 2 3
I don't love it it's kinda like oh TV
was yeah a little offended okay I like
G's into it let me do it oh my god
people are impressed I mean a lot of
people had a lot of fun eating this
really it's in quality of service more
than the consistency of the cheesy
potato I think it just puts a smile on
people's faces okay that we can agree on
that
[Music]
you
[Music]